hello everyone
today i'd like to provide an overview of
the precision medicine movement
and spend a bit of time focusing on
innovations that have led to advances
and the success in the immuno oncology
field
the war on cancer began in 1971
with president nixon's national cancer
act
three decades later a new era emerged in
the fight against cancer
called personalized or precision
medicine
according to the precision medicine
initiative launched by president obama
in 2015 persistent medicine
is an approach for disease treatment and
prevention
that takes into account individual
variability
in genes environment and lifestyle
for each person the
disease area where precision medicine
has had the biggest impact thus far
is oncology the success of precision
medicine is being built on
innovations in research technology
and policies for example
advances in basic research have
increased our knowledge
of cancer genetics as well as the immune
system's response to tumor cells
this has led to drug and therapy designs
that target cancer-specific antigens
and those that activate the immune
system to recognize
tumor cells as foreign
advances in testing technology
and data analysis have allowed us to
identify
more complex tumor biomarkers as well as
critical biomarkers
of the tumor microenvironment some of
these biomarker assays
evolve into companion and complementary
diagnostic assays
that play a central role in matching
patients
to new therapies or in guiding
the dosing and sequence of these
therapies
innovative clinical trial designs such
as
basket and umbrella trials and new
regulatory policies
have accelerated the approval of
precision medicine therapies
especially those for rare patient
populations
the precision medicine movement began
with molecularly targeted therapies
the identification of genetic
alterations in cancer cells
in the genes that you see listed here
and the classic
classification of those alterations that
are considered driver mutations
has led to an impressive list of
therapies
targeting tumors that harbor these
aberrations
it'd advances in pcr and highly
multiplex
platforms like next generation
sequencing
have led to a better understanding of
the different genetic profiles that
exist
across tumor types
these testing platforms have also helped
us understand that there are molecular
subtypes
that make up a disease such as non-small
non-small cell lung cancer
and breast cancer and these platforms
have also enabled the discovery of rare
targetable alterations such as entract
fusions
advances in these technology platforms
have also allowed molecular testing to
expand from research laboratories
into clinical routine testing
now this timeline showing innovations in
targeted therapy development
is not a comprehensive picture of all
of the targeted therapy and companion
diagnostic approvals
but i would like to point out a few of
the key milestones
that were driven by innovation
herceptin was the first targeted therapy
to be approved
in 1998 along with an ihc based
companion diagnostic assay called the
hercep
test the initial drug approval was for
her two positive metastatic breast
cancer patients
but the the approval was later expanded
to include
her two positive gastric cancer
additional ihc and fish-based acetate
fish-based assays have also been
approved
to identify patients with tumors that
overexpress
her2 this launched
the era of precision medicine
the next milestone that benefited
patients
with another prevalent cancer type was
the approval of several therapies
during 2013
these therapies that targeted non-small
cell lung cancer
harboring egfr mutations
along with the drugs the first pcr-based
companion diagnostic assays were
approved
that detected egfr mutations
initially the approval of drugs and
companion diagnostics
was what could be described as a
one-to-one model
one assay was approved as a companion
diagnostic
for one drug and a drug one drug
had a single approved companion
diagnostic
that model slowly changed over time and
in 2017
the one drug one diagnostic paradigm
shifted even further with the approval
of the first
next generation sequencing based cdx
assays
creating the one diagnostic for many
drugs model
the oncomine dx target test and the
foundation one
companion diagnostic test were both a
pro
approved for multiple targeted therapies
including those that targeted egfr
alk and b raf mutations
as more targeted options became
available for the treatment of solid
tumors
the availability of tissue samples for
molecular profiling
became a challenge the next innovation
noted on this timeline
is the development and approval of
companion diagnostic assays
that utilize plasma derived circulating
free dna
rather than tumor tissue for analysis
there are now both pcr and next
generation
sequencing based liquid biopsy companion
diagnostic
tests last but not least
innovations in clinical trial designs
and regulatory strategy
led to the first tumor agnostic drug
approval in 2019. victrackbay
was approved for any solid tumor
harboring
an end-track fusion
moving on immuno-oncology is the term
used to describe the next major phase of
the precision
medicine era the observation that the
immune system could play a role
in destroying a tumor was made almost 50
years ago
however many more decades of basic
science research were needed
before we could apply our understanding
of the checks and balances that exist
within the immune system
to the development of cancer targeted
therapies
the first class of a first class of
immunotherapies
included interferons and interleukins
etc they provided a general
enhancement of the immune system but did
not specifically direct the immune
system
toward cancer cells
excuse me checkpoint inhibitors are a
type of immunotherapy
that is more targeted to cancer cells
and really
put immunotherapy on the map
checkpoint molecules exist to prevent
earth
to prevent our immune system from
attacking normal cells
however tumor cells can also express
the checkpoint molecules as a means of
avoiding
immune cell attack drugs called
checkpoint inhibitors block these
molecules allowing
immune cells to attack the cancer cells
other classes of immunotherapy include
monoclonal antibodies
and bisph by specific antibodies
these antibodies are synthetic proteins
that are designed to bind to
specific tumor antigens
in some cases this interaction can
trigger an immune response to the tumor
cells
bispecific antibodies are different in
that they
not only target the tumor antigen
but take it one step further and also
bind to proteins on the surface of
immune
cells bringing the t cells closer to the
tumor cells
to trigger an attack
cellular immunotherapies are derived
from cells
isolated from donors in other words they
use
our own immune cells
either we can isolate and expand the
populations ex vivo
and then infuse them back into the
patient
or take those cells and engineer them
to be better equipped to tack and attack
a cancer cell
in the remaining slides i'll be focusing
on diagnostics for checkpoint inhibitors
and cellular immunotherapies
on the left half of this timeline i've
noted some of the major
research milestones that paved the way
for the development
and approval of cancer immunotherapies
starting with a cancer a prostate cancer
vaccine
in 2010 followed by the approval of the
first
checkpoint inhibitor yearbook your boy
or ippylumamab in 2011.
your void targets the ctla-4 checkpoint
two additional checkpoint inhibitors
hetruda
and opdevo charted targeting the pd-1
molecule
were also approved for melanoma
since then the list of approved
indications for anti-pd1 therapies has
continued to grow
in the last five years there have been
approvals of
innovative combination therapies such as
combinations of two different types of
immunotherapy
or one type of immunotherapy combined
with standard chemo
or radiation in 2017
there was also the first tumor agnostic
approval in the immunotherapy field
this is where ketruta was approved for
the treatment
of microsatellite instability high
solid tumors and i'll be explaining a
little bit more about that in the coming
slides
how are patients identified who are most
likely to respond to checkpoint
inhibitors
since the target of several of the first
immunotherapies
that were approved was the pd1pdl1
pathway levels of expression of pdl1
were investigated in many trials as
being a predictive biomarker
of response several immunohistochemistry
based
companion diagnostics and complementary
diagnostic assays
have been approved and you'll see those
in this table
while there are many tumor indications
that have been approved for the drugs
pdl-1ihc assays have only been approved
for certain tumor types to identify
patients who are most likely to respond
so why are more biomarkers and
diagnostics needed
to guide the selection of patients for
treatment with checkpoint
inhibitors most importantly the
complexity
of matching a therapy to a tumor
plus the tumor micro environment is far
greater than
simply matching a drug to a genomic
mutation
some patients whose tumors are negative
for pdl-1
expression have also responded to
checkpoint
inhibitor therapy in addition it's
important to notice
or to note that there are now multiple
approved targeted
immunotherapy options for treating
cancers
such as non-small cell lung cancer and
melanoma
therefore the validation of diagnostic
assays
that provide the most info with the
least amount of tissue
would be highly valuable
finally it's important to recognize that
other practical factors
such as cost turnaround time and
access to high complexity testing
are important to consider
in the development and launch of
companion diagnostic
assays
in the next few slides i'll be covering
potential
companion diagnostics for checkpoint
inhibitors
these include microsatellite instability
tumor mutation burden and various gene
expression
signatures let's start with
microsatellite instability or msi
tumors are classified as msi high
low or stable msi is a term
used to describe a phenotype that is
linked to an impaired dna mismatch
repair system
this defect can be caused by inherited
or acquired
defects in mismatch repair genes
the link between response to checkpoint
inhibitors
and msi status is based on the premise
that
higher levels of mutations will lead to
the over
or lead to the expression of higher
levels
of non-self or neo antigens
which will result in higher activation
of the immune system
this figure comes from one of the many
anti-pd-1 checkpoint inhibitor studies
showing higher levels of
progression-free survival
and overall survival in patients that
have
msi high tumors
there are many testing options or
methodologies available
that vary in complexity level for
determining
msi status or deficient mismatch repair
status
these include immunohistochemistry
assays
pcr-based assays and next-generation
sequencing assays several of these
assays are currently under development
as companion diagnostics for checkpoint
inhibitor therapies
another potential predictive biomarker
that is based on the hypothesis
that higher level mutations will result
in higher levels of
immunogenic tumor antigens is tumor
mutation burden
or tmb tmb is defined as the total
number of somatic coding mutations
and expressed as mutations per megabase
this figure is taken from a study of
pooled data
comparing objective response to tmb
levels
in 27 different tumor types
you can see there's a correlation
between tmb
and objective response rate with
anti-pd-1 or anti-pdl
one therapies
testing options for tmb are
all based on next generation sequencing
either whole exome sequencing or
targeted sequencing panels can be used
to measure tmb
tumor mutation burden testing methods
and data analysis
as you can imagine are highly complex
there are similar challenges with the
use of tmb
as there are with pdl1 ihc
these challenges are lack of
standardization
between test methods and variability
in setting the appropriate cutoff for
different tumor types
in addition the turnaround time for tmb
testing can be quite long up to several
weeks
making it impractical for true patient
treatment decisions
however in 2020 the keynote 158 trial
was used to approve
ketruda for the treatment of tmb
high tumors that have progressed after
previous treatment
and for those who have no satisfactory
alternative treatment options
the foundation one cdx test
was co-approved for this limited
indication
other tmb tests on the development of
other tnb
tests as companion diagnostics
is art is pending
it's important to note that tumor
mutation burden
is not the same as msi high
status msi high is associated with
higher tmb
but not all tmb high tumors
are due to a defect in mismatch repair
this data is from our lab where we
compared
msi and tmb status in a set of
colorectal cancer samples
you see one case on the far right
exhibited
exceptionally high tmv levels
but was found to be microsatellite
stable
mutation profiling revealed a critical
mutation in the pole e gene in this case
the poe gene encodes a protein
involved in dna proof reading
additional studies are needed to
determine if mutations in pole
e and pole d or other dna repair
genes may also be predictive of response
to checkpoint
inhibitors
final category i'd like to talk about
today are gene expression
profiling our gene expression profiles
as potential companion diagnostics for
checkpoint inhibitors
inflammation signatures of the tumor
micro environment
are being evaluated as predictive
biomarkers
for checkpoint inhibitors the signatures
include as few as four genes or as many
as
50 different genes and are designed to
provide
an inflammation score or immune
cell score all of the methods utilize
rna extracted from tumor tissue
many papers have been published on
different gene expression signatures
in this publication a targeted rna-seq
panel called the oncoming immune
response research assay
was used to assess the correlation of
two different signatures
with anti-pd-1 therapy in non-small cell
lung cancer patients
both two different signals
signatures one called the m1 signature
and the other the peripheral t cell
signature
were better at discriminating between
durable clinical benefit
and non-durable clinical benefit then
pdl-1ihc or tumor mutation burden
more work is needed to establish
and validate these signatures as
companion diagnostics
the last class of immunotherapy that i'd
like to
share with you is cellular
immunotherapies
with and there are several different
types here with
till or tumor infiltrating lymphocytes
specific subsets of immune cells are
isolated from a patient
expanded x vivo and infused back into
the patient
in this situation the treatment is
similar to sending in more troops
but without any extra gear
with t cell receptor and car cell
therapies
this involves taking t or nk cells from
patients
but instead of just activating and
expanding the available
anti-tumor t or nk cells
the cells are engineered to target
specific cancer antigens
then they are expanded in culture and
given back to the patient
now this therapy is like sending in more
troops
that have been given or have been
equipped with special gear
to recognize and attack the enemy
so far four car t therapies have been
approved
all four target cd19 and different
types of b-cell neoplasms
with cellular immunotherapy diagnostic
assays are needed for patient selection
or can be needed for patient selection
on treatment monitoring
and long-term safety assessments
a range of testing platforms can be
needed and utilized
including immunohistochemistry pcr
flow cytometry and next-gen sequencing
here's a list of some of the tumor
antigens
being targeted by engineered cellular
therapies
the need for a companion diagnostic to
identify patients who are most likely to
respond to engineered cell therapies
depends on the prevalence of expression
of the cancer-specific
antigen
for example some targets such as cd19
are expressed on nearly all of the
b-cell neoplasms therefore a companion
diagnostic would not be
needed however the expression of more
unique targets
such as nye so 1 can vary from 20 to 90
depending on the tumor type therefore
a companion diagnose a companion
diagnostic assay
might be warranted
in this case in this case study of a
t-cell receptor therapy
trial ihc pcr
and nitrogen sequencing were used to
assess biomarkers
that could predict response
guest therapy is engineered to target
mage a3 and a6
initially both an ihc assay and an
rtqpcr
assay were used for or were used for
patient selection
the ihc assay however
utilized a pan-mage antibody so was not
specific to the a3a6 subtypes
whereas the custom rtqpcr assay
is designed to specifically detect
these subtypes within the tumor
other biomarkers were also of interest
and are listed here
and i'll show you some examples of the
data on the next
slide
in the phase 1 study ihc and pcr
for mage a3a6
were used was used for patient
enrollment
pdl1 expression was also of interest
as there was a potential for
developing a combo therapy of using the
tcr
therapy plus a checkpoint inhibitor
therefore the expression and
coexpression of maj
and pdl1 was also explored
as i mentioned gene expression
signatures
may be predictive of response to these
sith therapies
so targeted rna-seq was used to express
uh the profiles of tumor or
immune cells various immune cells in the
tumor microenvironment
that could be used potentially to
predict response
you can see examples here of some
samples
where there was depletion of key
and critical immune cell subsets
in conclusion the development of cancer
immunotherapies has provided an expanded
arsenal
in the war on cancer predictive
biomarkers and diagnostics will help
clinicians
utilize this arsenal in the most
effective way
possible innovations as well as
coordination
between clinical translational
regulatory
and commercial teams is needed to
identify
validate and launch diagnostic assays
that will advance the precision medicine
revolution thank you